هل تقلق في هذا السياق بشأن
إيران التي لم تعد تشعر بالحاجة
إلى الالتزام بالاتفاق النووي الذي
وضع بالفعل
عمليات تفتيش كبيرة للغاية وقيودًا كبيرة جدًا
على برنامجها النووي ، نعم ، أعني
فريد عندما كنت قائد
المنطقة المركزية  الأمر
الذي أمسكنا به أن إيران ليست مسلحة بسلاح نووي
تحاول قتل سفير عربي على
بعد ميلين من البيت الأبيض
، وهي تُظهر كيف أن الشعب
الإيراني رهينة نظام
لا يضع مصالحهم في الاعتبار
الآن.  فعل أي شيء حيال ذلك في
ذلك الوقت ، لكن هل يمكنك أن تتخيل بلدًا
كهذا من شأنه أن يفعل شيئًا
مسلحًا الآن بسلاح نووي
ولديه المزيد من القوة ويمكن أن
يطلق على هذا البلد الذي يستخدم
الإرهاب لقتل رئيس
الوزراء السابق  لبنان يستخدمون الإرهاب
لمحاولة زرع الفتنة في البحرين
، لقد استخدموا الإرهاب في جميع
أنحاء المنطقة في اليمن
الآن لأن الحرب كانت ستنتهي أنا
مقتنع غائب  الدعم الإيراني
منذ بعض الوقت ، كان من الممكن أن تجلب الأمم المتحدة
ذلك إلى المفاوضات
ولم يكن ليكون مثالياً لكن كان
بإمكاننا إيقاف هذه المأساة الهائلة ، لذا
سيتعين علينا العمل على إبقاء
أسلحتنا النووية بعيدة عن أيدي إيران.